Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to The Escapists 2.
Now, I'm doing well so far, not great,
But, hey,
I haven't been caught, I've only got a little bit of notoriety, and everything seems to be okay.
Gotta find a makeshift spear and I've gotta get out of this goddamn place before everybody kills me, but hey.
That's just the way this life works, isn't it? So I don't know where I'm gonna find a makeshift spear, other than
buying it. I don't know. Anybody got a makeshift spear?
(yells) HEY!
Anybody here got a speeeeaaaaaarrrr? (Great question to ask out loud Mark)
Anybody got a spear? No, but you got the components for spears. Jeez alright. I've been to your roll-call, can I leave now? (No)
Can I leave? I'm here. I've been here. I've done this. (grumbles) Can I go now, please?
(Markimoo groaning noises)
Pop and Dude are gonna get searched. Hopefully I don't get searched, but
Chances are rare, so what are
the odds that's gonna happen. I just got to make an appearance here,
I don't actually have to do anything. Okay, let's see what we got in the way of crafting.
We've unlocked
Ooooo.
A makeshift spear!
I can make that! If I had a stick, which I don't have.
I guess I could break a broom handle to get that.
What we got here? Ooo, yes please. Goddammit,
I'm so full. Hey, hey, put it away. Put it away. How do I put it away? No, no put it-
How do I put it away? Oh, God.
I forgot how to put it- How do I put it away? Ah! Okay, there we go. Good god.
(Sigh)
Such a pain in the douche. Alright, either way, we got free time now
So let's go make the best of it, by looting other people's stuff. Alright
So let's take another scout around because there's a lot of stuff here, okay, so parking lot over there
Walls are over there. There's a main parking lot over there
But getting through there is going to be probably the son of a bitch. Oh wait is there already?
Oh my God. There's already a makeshift spear in here
Just ready to go. No I didn't, what are you talking about? I wasn't nowhere. What are you talking about? I just have a makeshift spear
That's so cool
So it just creates objectives that it can you can actually accomplish instead of having to go through the arduous process of getting it-
OHHH!
Well, I got this guy a spear then so that's good. Oh, I got to go upstairs. Aw shit...
And the diamond Minecraft (DanTDM uhhh... ) manicure kid alright cheer. I'll get you that later
Neeeeerrrrrrrdddddd
There just one more for a day at the Spa, which
honestly
It's kind of nice of all the things that people have been able to
Want me to get it better than a makeshift spear. Just give them a nice relaxing day at the Spa
Oh, don't come this way. Nope. I wasn't doing anything in there. You didn't see nothing doodlee doodlee
Laduhduh duh du dudududu lee dee de dee ee lee dee dee dee  eeee~ yaubudubo
No, God he went in there
Okay, I don't got nothing. I don't got nothing oh, I got a craft a manicure kit.
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!
That's what I gotta do. I can't get to my job soon, but I now manicure kit nice. Oh, I got it
Officer Banhoart where you at? You scoundrel? I've got a good thing for you. I'm shifting it
How hard can I shift it? I'm trying to deliver officer
There you go you got it you got a buddy. I'm getting a move on but just so you know. I love you
Love you very much (*blows kiss*)
You're my pride and joy. I'm not late. I'm not late. I'm not late. I'm not late. I'm not late. I'm not lay
I'm not late. I got a lot of suspicion, but I'm not late not late not late not late night late not
not not not not late gimme money!! I don't want a job, but give me money all right
oulll rioggghhhttt, oulll rioggghhhhttt all riooghhht fan turn out the cooking you can going to cruise whenever you bore me ah
Never listen to a word I said go on gil. I listen I listen
Don't give up on me. I won't give up on you. It looks like
My best bet is going to be going through the south area
But I'm gonna need a lot of materials to be able to do that. Blam blam
Blam I'll blam okay. Oh. Yeah, that was good stuff
What do you got Linds?
Linds has a vent cover. Sure why not let me get somewhat of a shower
And then I gotta get moving on plant this vent cover is apparently that's something that you just have
Da Da!
Done alright that's easy. Yeah, these are easy alright, but how much money do I have the question?
Still got that makeshift spear because they didn't actually deliver to the person
Flood Dan the diamond Minecraft toilet anything to do that on his own haha
(*laughs awkwardly and shakes head*)(They know each other irl heh)
Sorry, gah. Just walk right in there without you even think about it. Well Officer Hood you have a good day, okay goodbye.
Flush. I don't have anything to flush. What do I flush down there
Toilet plepper, sugar cubes, tub of toothpaste. That'll do that'll do that'll do big
What ahhhhhh
Nice, okay, so second day relatively uneventful because I was just preparing I have to get this stuff to craft more things
But it's really nice because some of these quests actually get me to the place
I need to go with that so once I get there
I'll be able to do more, but until then I got to play the fool. Alright good there
I'm gonna find the baseball mitt and then I'm good to go on that front
And I'm gonna start trying to find the materials. I need to be able to build what I need to build okay guys shit, man
Okay
Whoa
Like oh, I didn't get that I thought I got that oh he was unconscious!
Aw I thought I got that that that officer was uncwonscious
Ahhhhhh Bull Honkey. All right Leslie, Leslie put you up this
I'm a stab the shit out of him alright who needs to be put down. I've got me, uh, I've got me something for wumping
I've got a bunch of whump. It's about to be delivered to your head
With a spear I could kill someone couldn't it seems like that could kill somebody yeah, Imma deal with my fists
Here comes the bar trent. Whoa. That was a charge. I smell a trap. Oh you ready Leslie? Yu. I don't think you are
Whoopsies well Leslie here comes a thunder
Mrrssk oh that's an interesting attack. You're not being-
Oh shitt
(*Intense concentrated look*)
Bap! Bap!
Gotcha oh
Box maybe I can smash up the old box you didn't see nothin I saw nothing you saw nothing definitely
I just beat the shit out of him, so I did all right. What do I do with this old box?
I stole your shit stole your shit. I'm not stealing anybody's shit. That's for damn sure him steal your shit on your shit
I'll sell your shit dude. I stole your shit. I'm about to make the most
Unbelievable contraband this world has ever known
I'm gonna make a goddamn bed dummy gimme a goddamn bed dummy now!
Got them. Oh two pillows, gotta be super comfy forgot about that
(*Awkward Markimoo laugh*)
Alright now we're gonna make a goddamn bed dummy. It's gonna be super comfy you're gonna see craft it up there we go
Alright now. I'm gonna put that in the contraband ah all right?
So we got a bed dummy so that at night we can do some still
It's almost the end of free time here, gonna be lunchtime. I want to miss lunchtime. We feel like one's done once times good
Lunchtime it's fun time as I always say lunch time fun time that's how it goes ah yeah, the spoons. I forgot about the spoons
Don't get a bunch of spoons
Spoons ain't gonna be very good. I know spoons ain't good. But spoons spoons or spoons. You know it's spoons of spoons
That's what my daddy always taught me a spoon two spoons. Damn this food is not gonna do this a lot of good
I forgot how bad spoons actually were. So maybe that's not the best course of action. Watch out guys. I got my spoon
Guys see my spoon you missed why is that guy ahh...
Why is that guy in a construction hat with exercise time that don't make no sense hula doodly doodly doodly
(Another weird sound)
Alright, that's that
Like a dead rat I gotta put a dead rat in Frankie's desk. Yeah, that's horrible. Why would I do that I?
Why would I do that?
I mean I'll do it but not I'm not gonna be happy about it
Okay, put a dead rat there don't know why I did that
But it did it. Oooo information is it these are the hints right forget about that.
Ahhhhhh
I'm hoping someone got something good at this uh
Roll call cuz I'm gonna be looking cuz I got a lot of gold. Do I have a lot of gold? Yeah
I got 255 money, so I gotta use it
Down there
There we go. I need tool handle that's what I need. I need tool handles to be able to build more tools
Yeah, that's the goods. Ooh contraband pouch is also good
Drop this. When I get that contraband pouch on duuwww. There's another tool, buy that
What does that do for me that add to my inventory or something?
But I- I bought it where did
Where'd it go!?
What?!!
What ....
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Was this part of the thing I broken? Oh, I didn't do that. I didn't do that. I didn't do that
That was not me. I was innocent
And he hit me first noooooo don't get me
Nothing about me need nothing to nobody alright, so I'm going to actually stay up tonight. Yeah, nice
They'll never know
HEE HEEHEE HEEE
I'm sleep slopping. I'm sleep slurping don't mind me, so I'm gonna take the screwdriver. I'm gonna put this
Screwdriver can actually break down this wall. I highly doubt that but alright whatever whatever you saying okay, so the it's up here
I pick this up
Here jump up there. Nope one over woooahhhh oh
No, don't open it
Alright....
Monkey going you're going keep going oh yeah. Oh yeah, that's a good stuff. Oh now
We're getting somewhere ah now we're getting somewhere
I'll take that
Okay, alright, then exactly coming over here. It wouldn't matter right up up on the thing in here up on the thing in here
Okay, so we're off
So let's just see where this leads. I doubt any of the vents are just gonna
Go outside that would be stupid so all the vents go to the other
places
That vent goes to the library
Well good to know good to know
Don't know where as they should I wouldn't expect them to go anywhere really?
But I could get out of my cell by going through here
And just dropping down if I was able to avoid the patrols that is something that I could do
It is an option. Ooh where does that drop off that looks like a drop off there might be a bit farther forward
Might be a good idea, but I don't think I have time to do it tonight. I'm just gonna rest
And I'll hit it tomorrow, but I got I guess I got a little bit of a start here
Get rid of some of this bullshit. Oh, I hope they don't find anything in mine. I've got a lot of crap here.
Ah whatever. I just gotta go I'm picking up my pace. My pace is as picked. He's gonna get
75 Gold whoa energy module, paper clip, roll of duct tape?
Okay, I don't know what you want me to do, but I'm sorry I god damnit. I did it again
What did I do? I hit "I"?  Why does "I"..... OHHH "I" is hit. I thought it was inventory for some stupid reason
Energy module, I don't know who just left an energy module lying about but that's pretty convenient for me
I don't even know what it- Ah what are you doing? No! No, the duct tape did you find the duct tape no this needs
reporting oh
What did I do? Damage to the (*low yells*)
AHHHHH doggy
(*Yells weirdly*)
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!!
Oh, okay
Well, that's not good that doggy wanted a piece of me
Yeesh yeesh I forgot to put the uh
the vent cover back on I guess or they found that the bullet. Oh boy no no no no no no no no oh
God, I was just doing that for funzy onesies. I wasn't actually doing nothing. Well. That's no good, but that's alright
I just gonna go get the duct tape now. Oh, why is it it? It's in an evidence locker
It's just duct tape I have duct tape. I don't need that duct tape do I? Oh pish-posh
Bark bark
oh.... (*more screaming*)
Frick ,Jesus, you guys suck you guys suck this what again, it's my first time oh
This is incredibly difficult.... all right, I will okay anyway, so that's all the time I got for this episode of Escapist. This is
Quite difficult, but I can do this I think
Anyway, I think I can ,therefore, I can right? That's how it works all right, whatever
I'm off than at them. So thank you everybody so much for watching in the next episode I guarantee
I will be escopied from this place. No matter what so thanks again, and as always I will see you in the next video
Buh Bye! (Subbed by Andrea C. *^*)